[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is luis von on you can find him on
twitter at luis l-u-i-s-v-o-n-a-h-n
luis is an entrepreneur and consulting
professor at carnegie mellon university
who is considered one of the pioneers of
crowdsourcing he is known for
co-inventing captchas being a macarthur
fellow and selling two companies to
google in his twenties he's currently
the co-founder and ceo of duolingo a
language learning platform created to
bring free language education to the
world with more than 500 million users
it is now the most popular language
learning platform and the most
downloaded education app in the world
luis has been named one of the brilliant
10 by popular science one of the 50 best
brains in science by discover one of the
innovators under 35 by mit technology
review and one of the 100 most creative
people in business by fast company luis
also won the 2018 lemelson mit prize the
largest cash prize for invention in the
united states
luis it has been a while since we spoke
last it was 2016 when we had a
conversation on this podcast welcome
back it's nice to see you
thank you for having me tim
and i thought we could start with just a
few
bits of
trivia a little bit of history and why
don't we start with
why the duolingo owl is green would you
mind just explaining that for people
yeah so hopefully most people have seen
the duolingo owl um it's our mascot
first of all it's an owl because in in
most western countries owls represent
knowledge
turns out this is just not true at all
in asia and now that we've been
expanding to asia people ask us like why
the hell are you using and owls are just
kind of vicious animals but okay it's a
now and it's green and it is a
ridiculous reason why it's green we when
we were getting started my co-founder
severin who's an amazing guy his last
name is hacker severin hacker best name
ever
i still think it's made up he swears
it's not
this is a this is a computer science
person whose last name is hacker
but he
you know we were getting started and we
had a design team that was that was
working on our
on our logo and everything and we
thought we wanted a mascot we thought it
was important to have a mascot because
well it would kind of help people learn
and it would make our brand iconic etc
and that turned out to be true
and we came up with the idea of an owl
and then you know we were just talking
about things and then severine was not
very involved in the design process at
all
and
at some point the designers asked them
well is there anything you care about in
terms of the sign he said look there's
only one thing i care about and it is
that i hate the color green
and so we thought it would be funny if
uh
he was the co-founder of a company where
most of our colors
were green
and uh that's he's had to live with that
for you know 10 years
all right
and we we will try to not replicate too
much of the first conversation but i
think a little connective tissue and
context for folks would be helpful
so
i'm going to try to do a quick recap of
a few points and i want you to
correct anything that i get wrong
and certainly add in any color that you
think would be helpful so so you were
born and raised in in guatemala and
you
were raised by two parents both medical
doctors you
ended up
i think it started with receiving a
commodore 64. much to your
disappointment instead of a nintendo
becoming involved with taking things
apart and learning computer science
and flash forward
you
and skipping a lot of steps here but had
developed a technology and a company
recaptcha which after
about a year and a half sold to google
most people have filled out a captcha or
recaptcha to prove they are not a robot
or a bot
and a year and a half later
this severant hacker who you've already
mentioned who is then a phd student of
yours was looking for a phd project
and
that led to a conversation
including the observation that number
one language or i should say education
was important to both you and that in
your home country of guatemala
education was in a sense
a
an obstacle to overcoming socioeconomic
barriers
and to elevating your life because of
the costs involved so the rich were able
to educate themselves and sort of
perpetuate that cycle of wealth whereas
the poor were not and
there were many many different
facets of this
which led then to what would later
become duolingo is that roughly accurate
that's exactly right okay can we can
wrap up now we're done
all right and and you and i i don't know
when you and i
i can't recall offhand when we first
connected
i want to say somewhere between 2010 and
2012. it must have been it was around
2010 or 2011.
yeah so right in that range
and
early early days with respect to
duolingo and the last time we spoke you
had
this was in 2016 last time we spoke on
the podcast
roughly 60 employees so could you just
give us a then and now comparison of
duolingo then
duolingo now
what the biggest differences are
yeah i mean so we we've grown a lot as a
company of course we we now have about
600 employees so of course 10x in
employees um we we used to be back then
we were a private privately held company
vc funded we are now a publicly traded
company that was a big
a big milestone for us another big thing
that changed between 2016 and now is we
really figured out how to monetize
duolingo
when we launched duolingo the thing we
cared the most about is that it was a
free way to learn languages and
at first we just weren't concerned too
much about
figuring out how to make money
and the way we supported ourselves was
through venture capital we just kept on
raising you know more and more venture
capital and
at the time the prevailing wisdom was
hey don't worry too much about making
money just grow your users and this is
what we did and the way we grew our
users by the way is not through
marketing because since we weren't
making any money we thought it was
kind of a waste of our money to
spend to acquire users uh if we weren't
making money on the other side so the
way we grow our users was just by making
the product better and better and it
grew through the word of mouth
and i think what one thing that happened
is around 2015 2016
you know we had raised a bunch of
venture capital i mean
probably around 100 million dollars
total at the time and we still weren't
monetizing at all but we had grown to a
pretty good amount of users active users
we raised a round of funding from
at the time it was called google capital
and now it's called capital g
and
the partner that was that was on our
board leila sturdy
took me out to a bar and she said listen
you've been raising a lot of capital and
your valuation keeps going up and up at
the time i think we're valued at
something like half a billion dollars or
something
but right now you're just raising money
from google
and let me tell you
there is no bigger fool like you're not
gonna find another bigger fool to raise
money at a higher valuation with no
revenue
you gotta figure out how to make money
and so she gave me enough drinks that
convinced me to promise her that next
time we spoke in six months i would have
figured out how to make money
and so i went back and like all right
everybody we gotta figure out how to
make money
and we did but it was very important to
us
we really cared that we
you know the easiest way to make money
when you're teaching somebody is just to
charge them to learn that's kind of how
education monetizes it's very important
for us that we didn't do that because
the mission of our company was really
you know related to giving access to
education to everybody for free
so
and we were a little
constrained here in the end we ended up
finding a monetization model that worked
out really well which is this freemium
model that is similar to what the dating
apps do or what spotify does which is
you don't have to pay but you may have
to see some ads at the end of a lesson
we make money from the ads and then if
you don't like the ads you can pay us to
subscribe to a premium version of
duolingo and then we turn off the ads
and we give you a few extra perks
and that combo worked out really well i
mean well enough that that that is
basically what we used to ipo you know
it has grown to hundreds of millions of
dollars of revenue so that worked out
really well and we're also very proud of
that because of that duolingo you know
it used to be that duolingo was was the
most downloaded app in the education
category it still is
but now it's also the highest top
grossing app in the education category
to make more money than all of their
education apps and we're very proud that
you can still use duolingo entirely for
free
so even though you know most other
education apps you have to pay to use
them hours in fact something like 97 of
our users so if our active users use
dual duolingo for free still we make
more money
and all other education have so we're
very proud of that the monetization has
was a big shift in our company
i have questions about monetization and
then i want to come back to layla and
talk about org chart maybe another
conversation maybe fewer drinks leila is
one of my favorite people layla is
awesome
yeah so we're going to come back to
layla and give her more credit
do you remember what types of drinks she
was feeding you do you have any idea or
did the memory go out the window you
know i i don't know that night honestly
i i don't know
yeah no problem he was at a bar near the
dueling office it's about a block away
from the dueling office kelly's kelly's
bar
kelly's bar all right it's the scene of
the crime so
we're going to come back to that i
wanted to return to monetization and
i'll just mention to folks as
foreshadowing the reason i'm interested
in talking about the org chart is
because again this will test my memory
of the first conversation but
as i recall when you sold
recaptcha to google you had maybe six
seven or eight employees something like
that yeah around 10. okay around 10
employees
and then
for a while i want to say maybe into
the 30 to 40 employee range you had a
very flat
organizational structure so to speak yes
effectively a lack of hierarchy at
duolingo and although you had a lot of
experience with
computer science certainly and product
development and thinking about the
technical side of things
building a company of 600 people was not
one of them at that point
i had no no previous knowledge of how to
do this no yeah right so that's why i
want to come back to the org chart but
first
on the monetization side what are some
of the things that you tried
that didn't
quite work and why did they not work
just in terms of whether primary or
ancillary
models
because
that that i recall as someone who is one
of the pioneers of crowdsourcing you
know you you certainly have come up with
many different ideas for how you might
approach this
the first thing we tried and this is
before the layla talk and it was just
very early on we tried this and it was a
really clever idea but ultimately i just
don't think it was a very good way to
monetize
very early on when we had started
duolingo what we said we would do is
look there were all these people that
were learning a language and duolingo
for free
we thought rather than giving them ads
or charging them
we would get them to do some work for us
in exchange of the learning and so the
idea was gonna was the following in fact
we we built this and it worked the idea
was the following
imagine you were a spanish speaker who
was learning english on duolingo
you know you would learn for free etc at
the end of your lesson we would say hey
you just practiced food words
do you want to practice with a real
world
news article about food
that is in english you're learning
english and to practice can you help us
translate that into your native language
of spanish
and you know we would give you like a
paragraph of that or something and then
we would give many people
you know the same paragraph and try to
get them to translate it and and it
turned out that actually got really good
translations so what what ended up
happening is we signed a contract with
cnn where cnn would
send us all their news in english then
our users to practice their english
would translate those articles into
spanish and then you know we kind of
combined all of the different
translations into one translation and we
had all this kind of multi-step process
to clean up the translation etc and then
we would send back a translated version
to cnn into spanish that they could post
in their spanish site and they would pay
us for that
so we signed a contract with cnn we
started contract with buzzfeed and this
worked and it sounds very clever
the problem is as a monetization
technique first of all translation is a
bad business to be in
computers are getting better and better
at it and even without computers it's
just kind of a race to the bottom in
terms of price
because you can always just find
somebody else to do it cheaper for you
so that was kind of one thing and then
we just we just ended up realizing this
was
not an easy way to make too much money
the other thing is we started realizing
because that's where the money was
coming from we started realizing we were
spending a lot of our thinking time and
a lot of our development time on making
sure the translations were accurate
whereas to begin with what we wanted to
do was make an education company right
and we wanted to spend most of our time
teaching better rather than cleaning up
translations
and so at some point very early in the
company we weren't making very much we
were making i mean it's like thousands
of dollars not a lot of money we decided
we took this this hard decision this was
must have been like 2013 or something we
took the hard decision to stop that
we're like we're not going to do that
and we're not going to worry about
making money
and we're just going to do venture
capital for a while like don't worry
about it
so that was one the other one is after
the layla conversation
when we needed to really figure out how
to make a lot of money now the thing is
when you have a half a billion dollar
evaluation
you got to make a lot of money like you
when you're making zero you can't make
it so that you're only going to make
thousand dollars a year like to justify
half a billion dollar valuation you have
to making you can't turn it into a
lifestyle business for yourself no you
gotta be making you know at least tens
of millions if not hundreds of millions
of dollars in revenue to have that yeah
by the way when layla said you have to
monetize i went back to the to the
company and you know at the time we had
maybe 60 70 employees and
i said okay well we had to figure out
how to make money and the first question
everybody had was like why
i was like well companies make money
that's how they support themselves and
they're like well we've been fine
without that
you know and then i had to explain you
just cannot raise venture capital
forever
then it's like okay fine we understand
we have to make money
so how are we going to do it and then i
would say well you know maybe we can put
an ad at the end of the release and no
no ads are evil don't don't put an ad
okay how about we you know have a
subscription note you can charge people
you can't you can't do that and so it's
like the whole company was basically
against monetizing and it took us about
six months to finally convince everybody
that monetization was not a bad thing
and that in reality what it would allow
is if we could make a lot of money we
could use that to invest it and to teach
better
and and people actually finally
understood but it took a while and
in that time at some point one of the
first few things that changed was people
were like okay you know what we could do
ads we could do ads but they can't be
the crappy ads that are all out there
let's do let's do a clever idea and the
clever idea was and it's a great idea we
just never made it work and i don't know
if at some point i do want to go back to
it
can we show ads in the language that the
people are learning
so if you're learning spanish could we
show you some ads in spanish
and i think that's a really good idea
because it's kind of like a win-win
situation like the person who wants to
actually hear the ad or see the ad they
they practice and then we make money off
of it there's one big problem for that
which is that usually companies
that their budget doesn't work that way
so for example in the u.s
and you're advertising two american
consumers
you know coca-cola i'm sure has an ad in
german but they just do not want to show
the german ad
that's just not what they want to show
because no no in german we have a very
different narrative that's just not what
we want to do we want to show the
american ad and we're like can we show
the german ad and it just that just we
never got it to work
i thought it was a good idea i never got
it to work in the end now we revert it
to showing standard app ads that we show
that are you know what you're supposed
to get if you are in in in the us you
get the english ads
may i just because i'm over caffeinated
just throw something out there really
quickly yep which is
and i'm sure with your technical
abilities you can figure this out all
right or the advertiser can just supply
the raw text of course for closed
captioning that they would use otherwise
but you could show the
translated subtitles in the target
language yeah say
of german yeah that is a good idea and
we probably shoot that at some point
there's one other complication with this
which is
right now
the ads we show
the programmatic ads that come from like
google and facebook like we show google
and facebook ads and and google and
facebook are the ones who serve us the
ads if we wanted to do something like
this we would have to have our own ad
sales force so we would have to go and
contact companies and ask them to do
that
that's doable and probably you can make
more money per ad impression if you do
that yeah but
it's the pain in the ass of having
basically a sales team yeah and so
because our monetization particularly
subscription has done so well
we haven't felt the need to do that i
mean at some point maybe we'll do it but
we just we just haven't felt the need to
do that
so i want to give you
credit where credit is due
on
i'm sure there are many things i could
give you credit for but one is
a
relentless focus and ability to refocus
and i want to mention an article for
folks it's very short that they might
find interesting it's called the top
idea in your mind it's by polygram
which relates back to the point you made
of realizing that you're not in the
business of tidying up the last five
percent of translations that
you have sourced from your users and in
fact you're an education company first
and foremost right
to being able to say no to a good even a
profitable
activity in order to remain focused just
as you would not want to necessarily
build your internal sales team right
because it would just detract
from the focus and resources
i want to return
with a question about the
months it took to convince
the
team the employees
to
get behind monetization of some form or
another how did you do that
and how much of it was like here is the
mission because presumably they care
about the mission of the company but
they also care about the value of their
equity and want liquidity at some point
so
you could just say okay guys
if we keep raising venture capital like
there might be secondary sales but at
some point
both the investors and employees will
want to be able to cash in on at least
some of the value of their equity that's
part of the reason you came to this
company rather than going to work for
someone else
what was the the conversation or the
process of persuasion you know it's
interesting the first few employees that
we hired at duolingo by the way it's an
interesting i think a lot of has to do
with the fact that we we have a really
good company culture but also that we're
in pittsburgh our employee churn is very
low so we
employees stay for a very long time at
duolingo so the majority of people that
started at duolingo you know 10 years
ago they're still around yeah and the
thing about these people was when we hi
the first few employees that we hired
were people from carnegie mellon
university because i was a professor
there and i basically i just knew who
the best students were and i'm like you
you want to come work for us
all these people at the time had offers
for you know the usual suspects you know
google and facebook and the usual
suspects
and at the time we had just raised our
serious a but we we could not compete
salary wise with google or facebook or
anything like that now
we can compete you know our salaries are
comparable to google or facebook but
back then we just couldn't
so the people that took a job with
duolingo
were taking a major pay cut sometimes
like 50 pay cut like we were paying half
the salary that they would have gotten
on google and they had offers at google
they took the job and the reason they
took the job was they were really
they really cared about the mission so
you know i'd like to tell severan and i
care about the mission these first few
employees were zealots they were like
look at this is the main thing that
matters to me and so
these people for years have been kind of
the guardians of the culture
and so it it dualing was a very
mission-driven company and of course it
has to do with seven and i but i think
it also has to do with this first few
employees who just really care and
they're still around and so when we were
starting to monetize
the discussion was really never about
like hey you could make a lot of money
off of you know your shares or whatever
that that that just didn't resonate all
that well
yeah for sure
what ended up resonating the most
was
hey look
right now we have about 60 employees
we could hire
way more employees if we can make a lot
of money and the majority of them can be
working on improving how well we teach
and that really resonated and it became
true i mean today most of our employees
are actually working on making our
product better in terms of how well we
teach how engaging it is and it is
because we make hundreds of millions per
year we use that to to fuel the mission
so i think i think there was just a
shift in thinking that really worked and
we believe it i mean i think the company
now believes that
i'm glad i asked these stories matter
and i don't know the answers by the way
if people listening uh i mean louise has
been
busy to put it mildly so we don't always
catch up very very frequently so this is
this is an excuse for us to catch up as
well let me ask you a question that i
would ask if we were just having drinks
over dinner i would not ask you to make
any promises
about
monetization to me but the the broader
question since you mentioned computers
getting better at translation so this
doesn't directly relate to duolingo i
don't think but it might in some
indirect way and for people who don't
know a bit of the history if if we look
back at say recaptcha part of what
fascinated me about recaptcha i was like
all right if you if you and i think you
did
run the kind of basic arithmetic on how
many human hours we're going into
verifying
that each individual is not in fact a
bot
you begin to wonder is there a way to
put put these human hours to work for
some benevolent purpose or a positive
purpose
and at least one facet of that ended up
being helping to digitize books
right so using human eyes
and then just kind of the law of large
numbers to ultimately get a
good
transcription of digital books that
machines were having a hard time with
what are some of the most interesting
things or interesting developments that
you are seeing with respect to
crowdsourcing versus just raw computing
power or new
technological
pure kind of machine driven
technologies
well you know computers are just getting
a lot better at things compared to 10
years ago 20 years ago ai is just a lot
better for example
at this point
it used to be that captchas were mainly
these distorted characters
at this point computers are almost as
good if not better than humans at
reading these distorted characters so
showing some distorted characters is not
a good test to distinguish humans from
computers anymore
if you've seen with recaptcha lately
what they show you is these kind of
images of like find the traffic light or
find the stop sign or find
what they're doing there is they're
crowd sourcing
things for like mapping software or
self-driving cars where you know
self-driving cars may take a lot of
pictures for things and they may see
90 i don't know the exact fraction but
they may see 90 of traffic lights and
realize that it's a traffic light but
for some of them they just can't quite
tell and so what recapture is doing is
it's taking some of the things where the
computer is not super sure about and is
getting people to kind of tell them so
that that's helping to improve the
you know technology
and so that's something you know i
really like that application i think
it's it's it's worked out pretty well
so that's helping to improve technology
now in case of language translation
that's gotten pretty good i mean if you
if you try it and it's kind of good
enough to go and if you're going to go
to germany or something it's kind of
good enough to like
if you don't know any german to just
kind of you know you speak to it and it
speaks out something and
you sort of can communicate you know
people have asked us about dueling was
like well do i will are people still
going to need to learn a language given
that translation is getting better and
better
and it's one of those we're like
i don't think this is going to affect us
at all
there are you know there are these use
cases like if you're gonna go on a
business trip for two days and you
really have no interest in learning a
language yeah sure use google translate
or use whatever whatever it is you you
need to use
but there's a couple of things first of
all
no matter how perfect the translation is
there's this thing that happens that
there's always going to be a delay even
even if it's like super computing power
etc because
word order changes
so german is a good example in german
usually the verb is at the end so a
german sentence you know the way you
would say it kind of in english is like
i did something yesterday i did it
really fast i did it
with my friend and what i did was run
and so you kind of have to wait until
the verb comes out
to start saying it in english because in
english you would say i ran with my
friend yesterday really fast
and so so there's always this kind of
like
pause that makes conversations pretty
awkward like you just this is just you
can't really live your life that way and
the majority of language learning is
either to learn english and actually you
know
say move to the us or actually learn
english for for business reasons etc you
actually want to learn english and then
the other big chunk is hobby
and you know people are still going to
learn as a hobby because
you know it's the same reason why we
learn you know all kinds of things that
computers could do really well like
music
so i just don't think that's going to
affect us as a as a company in terms of
language learning
yeah i don't either i mean i have been
incredibly impressed specifically with
google translate with respect to
in my case east asian languages because
i do
still communicate a fair amount in
japanese and to a lesser extent mandarin
but
the
translation specifically in japanese has
improved tremendously yeah it's good
yeah it's incredible you want to talk
about sentence construction and word
order changing uh certainly in japanese
that is that is true because it's
just for people who are interested in
this kind of thing but don't know very
much about it if you have say i
eat the apple in
english subject verb object in japanese
generally speaking it's going to be
subject object verb so i the apple e i
to the school go that kind of thing
and it's it's improved a lot but there
is that delay
as you mentioned and if if i look at
the
uh let's see i'm looking at duolingo.com
courses right now
and this may not be the best
representation of use on the platform
but i'm curious to know
who the primary
users are in the pie chart if you're
just going to break down kind of the the
top few categories and what they're
learning and i was surprised to look at
courses for english speakers
it looks like spanish is number one okay
not too surprised there
then french okay interesting very
interesting because you know french is
certainly spoken by the french
diaspora and other places not just in
france but it's a result of colonialism
right exactly so that's what i figured
colonialism but then you have japanese
korean german italian hindi chinese so
hindi chinese
i think specifically chinese i would
have expected to be a little
larger and i'm astonished that japanese
and korean especially korean because i
could even chalk up japanese to like
nerdy
tech folks who are japanophiles and love
japanimation and so on i could i could
chalk up some of that
to that which may not have any accuracy
to it at all it's 100 accurate okay all
right great and then korean though i was
like why korean why is korean number
four k-pop k-pop ah
k-pop
okay k-pop is humongous i mean k-pop and
also korean tv shows you know on netflix
there's just been korean entertainment
is
is really gaining a lot right
so yeah the squid game the movie games
called the one that won the oscar with a
basement i know the one you're talking
about parasite parasite
so stuff like that korean influence just
keeps growing and growing and so it is
interesting more people in duolingo are
learning japanese or korean than chinese
and chinese is an interesting one
chinese is there's the size of the
language in terms of native speakers
chinese is very large and in this case
we're talking about mandarin right man
right mandarin chinese yeah you know
it's the largest language in terms of
native speakers
and then there's a different number
which is the number of people who want
to learn it we have a pretty good idea
of the people who want to learn it
because when we offer it on duolingo we
can see the people you know how many
people actually learn it there's some
that are flipped i mean chinese is
flipped in that mandarin chinese is
flipped in that there's a lot of people
who speak it natively not that many
people are learning it so you know i
don't know exactly off the top of my
head but about one percent of our active
users are learning chinese
which i would have expected it to be
higher and in particular part of the
reason why i would have expected it to
be higher is because the circles that we
move in i assume they're similar to
circles you move in it's kind of
educated people tech people they always
have their kids learning chinese this is
like i think oh my kids are learning
chinese etc yeah this is the thing this
is a thing you go to palo alto it's like
every other parent has their kids in
sort of bilingual nursery school or
whatever yeah so you think the whole
world's learning chinese but this is
actually not the case if you go anywhere
in middle america you know the school
only offers spanish like that's just to
begin with right and i think there's
just a number of reasons but i think
probably the biggest reason for chinese
that not as many people are learning it
is it's just a very hard language to
learn yeah i think people know it and
they're like ah that's hard yeah so you
know in the us our top languages are
exactly as you said spanish which makes
sense we're very close to mexico and
latin america and it's this is a very
large language french which i think is
you know beautiful language and
everything but i think a lot of it that
one is the opposite of chinese in that
the number of people learning it versus
the number of people who are native
speakers you know it's just a lot of
interest for a french given
the number of native speakers
and then you know chinese and korean are
pretty high up and italian and uh german
now we have you know we were asking
about the types of users and i think we
have two big buckets of users i in my
head i classify them as kind of two big
buckets one big bucket which is about
call it 50 to 60 percent of our users
is people learning english
this these are people who are usually
not in the us they're i mean some of
them and they are in the us but they're
usually not in the us they're usually
you know in a non-english speaking
country and they're learning english
the reason they're learning english is
they actually want to learn english then
the reason is because they want to get
ahead in life so either they want to get
into a better educational institution or
they just want to get a better job the
thing about english that is so magical
is that anywhere you live
if you speak english just by speaking
english you can make more money
it's like direct so for example if you
used to be a waiter now you can be a
waiter at a hotel makes more money
if you used to be uh you know i don't
know personal assistant now you can be a
personal assistant for
somebody in a multinational corporation
or something so it's just
knowing english just gives you better
opportunities in life and and it's by
far the most learned language in the
world certainly by far the most learned
language on duolingo and those people
are very committed
and then
the other big bucket of people are
people who are
english speakers already who are
learning another language so think of
this as a person in the us who's
learning spanish or french etc they're
pretty different you know it's more of a
hobby obviously i'm generalizing here i
mean there are some people obviously who
need to move to spain and they're going
to learn spanish for that but for the
majority it's kind of more of a hobby
that they're learning this
you know japanese or spanish or whatever
the funny thing about these people is
when you ask them
what would you do if duolingo went away
the most common answer is i would spend
more time on instagram
they're not that committed they're like
ah you know what i like it the reason
i'm learning spanish on duolingo is
because you see i used to i don't know
play a lot of
whatever clash royale or a lot of some
game
and i was a complete waste of my time
now i'm using duolingo is pretty fun
and at the very least at the end of the
day i'm learning some spanish
so they're an interesting group of
people the other thing to say is in the
u.s 80 of our users were not learning a
language before duolingo that's amazing
so we're completely growing the market
that is not true in a country like
brazil where people are mainly learning
english these people were learning
english before duolingo they'll continue
learning english even if dueling were to
go away
so it's kind of these these are the two
big groups of people i'd say all right
so
i'd love to just get a fact check if if
you know here i mean maybe the math is
so easy that it's almost self-evident
but
i recall someone saying to me
which kind of makes sense
although i haven't done the math on it
that there are
more people who speak english or are
learning english
in china as chinese nationals than all
of the native speakers of english in the
world
combined
that's probably close close to true yeah
i would imagine that that might be
something like india as well i mean
although you do have the british
history yeah it's probably close
you know native speakers of english
let's think about that there's 300
million is in the us but then there's
the uk too yeah
and you know australia canada et cetera
they probably combine that another 100
million ish yeah so
very rough numbers here we're talking
about 400 million ish yeah it seems like
china's probably not quite there
well it could but there's a big big but
here
they may all claim be claiming to be
learning english and in reality they may
be learning english but the learning
outcomes may not be so good yeah so it's
like yes they're learning english but
you know the
maybe they know how to say hello and
good morning and you know where's the
bathroom but that's about it
so you know i just it's not clear that
they're you know really good in english
i do not believe that in china there are
400 million
really really fluent native speakers i
don't believe that to be true yeah i
don't believe that either
and anyone who travels widely in china i
think would probably come to that
conclusion
that just not the case yeah
so let's as i promised earlier come back
because i'd love to talk about some of
your lessons learned
key decisions
in a growing company of this size for
the first time and there are many ways
we can tackle this we'll talk about the
personal so just in terms of kind of
personal management
work life balance if that exists uh
lessons learned but let's let's also
come back to
the org chart and
layla could you describe
how that was done
what it ended up looking like
what were the implications and just just
kind of walk us through that and i
remember in our first conversation i
told the story of and maybe not the best
example uh since it is
ultimately has been superseded by
netflix and superior technology but
blockbuster back in the day when
blockbuster as a company was about to
become a blockbuster
brought in i believe someone from
mcdonald's and exec to specifically help
them with org chart design
i've never designed an org chart so
could you just describe
what happened and
where you landed with it
yeah i mean we've gone through a bunch
of different org charts i mean when we
were
from zero to
call it 30 employees our chat was was
very flat as in i was managing everybody
that was that and i actually think you
know maybe i took it a little too far
but i actually think in the first for
the first zero to n where n is around
maybe 20 to 30 people
the best thing you can do as a ceo is be
a micromanager i actually believe that
when you are such a small company
usually you don't quite yet have product
market fit you haven't really figured
everything out you have one goal get the
product market fit
and i don't think you should be in the
business of you know kind of like
coaching people for this or that no just
i think you just micromanage people to
like get to product market fit i
actually believe that
at some point it really shifts even if
you love micromanaging which i
love micromanaging but i've learned not
to do that anymore
even if you love it at some point this
is just becomes you just can't do it as
well and
it is in your best interest to start
actually developing people
and you know that shift should happen
maybe at around 20 i don't know the
exact number
that is when
you should really start
having kind of a couple of managers i
think splitting things up into teams
what we did then it's not like we had a
pretty good idea of exactly what our orc
judge should look like but what we did
was
we hired our first manager
that wasn't me
it's a woman that this was made i don't
know seven years ago something like that
it's a woman that's still with us she's
now the head of all of engineering she
used to be a director of engineering at
google
and i knew her because after selling
recapture i spent some time at google i
knew her i really liked her her name is
natalie glance she's amazing and she you
know she took a much smaller job at
duolingo she was managing you know kind
of it's a larger job that she had and
she took a smaller job at dueling i
think she really believed in us and she
helped us
well
from her eyes where i learned how to
manage people really much better she
actually knew how to manage people
and she really helped us you know kind
of start having a structure of well we
have some managers
and that was
that really made a big difference
starting to have teams then the thing
that we did after that is we discovered
this idea of metrics based teams which
to this day we use and i think it's been
a really really good thing i think this
is not the common thing although some
companies do do it it's not the common
thing so
at duolingo you know the standard thing
that you would have in a company for
example at duolingo we have the app has
a bunch of different features
one of the features could be like we
have a leaderboard for example a
leaderboard that's a feature
in many companies coming the normal
thing to do is that you have a
leaderboard team a team that owns that
big feature so just kind of you you
split it up by feature these are feature
based teams
we do not do feature based teams we do
metrics based teams so we don't have a
team that owns the leaderboard
instead we have a bunch of teams that
own each a single metric so for example
a metric that we have is time spent
learning
what they're what they own is
the number of minutes per day that the
average user uses duolingo for
and it turns out that changes to the
leaderboard increase
or can increase or decrease time spent
learning if you do kind of the right or
the wrong thing so that team messes with
the leaderboard a lot but they don't own
it the only thing they do is they have
this one metric and every quarter it has
to increase and so they just work on
increasing this one metric and they run
hundreds of a b tests to increase this
metric so
we discovered that you know soon after
natalie showed up we discovered these
metric based teams and we started you
know at first our first metric based
theme was a retention team which is look
all you have to do is make sure that
users come back every day
and that team
has done all kinds of things really
optimized the streak on duolingo so this
this notion of a streak that people have
yeah if people have used it what every
day for seven years i was looking at the
streaks the streak is crazy um we have
well the number is a little larger but
now that we're a public company we can't
reveal numbers as the latest number
we've revealed is that we have one and a
half million daily active users that
have a streak longer than a year meaning
they have not missed a single day in the
last year or longer
so so that that's a that's a very
powerful mechanic the retention team has
worked on that so basically what we did
is we discovered these metric based
teams and what we do now at dueling was
when we care about a metric that we want
to optimize so a metric could be daily
revenue
or or you know whatever it is we form a
team around that metric and that has
worked out pretty well that's kind of
one big shift with us
that happened and then the other big
shift that happened is so that that
worked out pretty well at some point we
we had like 50 teams i don't know maybe
a little less like 40 teams
and that was started to become
you know we use the term goat rodeo it
started to become this craziness and so
what we did is we we decided to pull the
teams together that were similar to each
other into this thing called areas so
now for example we have a monetization
area inside the monetization area we
have a team that owns ad revenue per day
we have a team that owns subscription
revenue per day we have a team so so
that and then we have another area
called the growth area where it's just
growing our active users we have a team
that owns time spent learning we have a
team that owns
retention we have another team that owns
new user retention
etc and so
we we split up into areas and that's how
we're split up now
and
what has what has been really good is
and the shift for me has been you know
it went from micromanager to kind of
learning how to manage to
now
what i do is i you know i'm a manager of
managers well i'm a manager of managers
of managers and managers but at some
point that kind of doesn't matter that
much you're just you're just a manager
of managers is kind of what matters
and i've learned how to start managing
managers much better i've gotten good at
it
all right last time we spoke i have a
number of follow-ups here let me ask the
easy one might not be the easy one to
answer but the easy
simple question first which is
why
a daily metric as opposed to a different
time interval like a weekly
for instance
in terms of revenue or something else
there's two reasons for daily stuff
one is we're really big believers that
you should be using duolingo every day
and just basically you don't have to use
duolingo every day to learn a language
but we really want to build a habit
and the best habits are daily i think
because it's kind of hard to have these
habits that are like well every three
days i do something like that's just
kind of hard it's much much better to
have a habit like brush my teeth
just do it every day
so we try to build habits every day and
so for us
this is one of the reasons why we look
daily the other reason why we look daily
is that we run a lot of a b tests and
looking at the daily time frame allows
us to move faster so because
we just don't have to imagine that our
time frame was a month we said look how
many people do x in a month
we have to wait a whole month to figure
out what that number is right is that
because you're just controlling for
confounding factors if you're running if
you're changing multiple variables at
the same time it just becomes too
difficult to attribute causation so the
lag time just becomes long that's
exactly right so whereas if you look at
daily stuff
it's much faster so for example for
revenue we really we look at daily well
daily bookings to be precise is
basically the amount of money that comes
into duolingo
we look at that a lot and we optimize
that and it really is nice because you
can see for example if we make a change
you can see tomorrow
what happened in the change today you
can you can already see ah yes daily
bookings increase by you know 10
you can see it in one day
so those are the two reasons why we look
at the daily i mean we've talked about
starting to do hourly
we haven't quite done that i know one of
the difficulties with our leads there's
a pretty big differences in in terms of
times i mean for example 9 p.m around 9
p.m is the most popular time to learn a
language
but there are times for example 4 a.m
there's just not very many users and so
looking at hourly makes it a little
harder
but
we do daily
so before we move on i'd love to just
clarify one thing that you said and that
is related to the micromanaging and
whether that point is at 10 people 20 30
but it was related to being
pre-product market fit
would it be safe to say that if you have
product market fit let's just say you've
you've created a business model and a
business that is generating revenue that
has found its match
that it would potentially make sense to
develop people
sooner
than the 10 people 20 people or whatever
the head count might be
i think that makes sense it just
hopefully you're not in a period where
you're doing this kind of zero
you know zero to 20 employees for for
eight years or something hopefully that
period only lasts one or two years yeah
and in that time
you probably just need to be trying to
figure out product market fit if you're
gonna be in that for several years
i do think it starts making sense
developing people
all right
so to
let's say just hop back to our first
conversation there were two books that
you mentioned as being particularly
helpful
or that you would recommend maybe both
one was zero to one by peter thiel
and the other was the hard thing about
hard things if i'm getting the title
right i can never remember this title by
ben horowitz yes and i'm wondering if
now flashing forward from 2016 to
present you've gone from 60 to 600 or so
people a lot has changed you've gone
from private to public are there any
other books
or resources
or thinkers who you have found
particularly
helpful or helpful at all in the last
handful of years
one book that i really liked
and we make all managers read it at
duolingo is it's an oldie it's an oldie
but but a really good one is
high output management
by andy grove
it's just
it's just like a how-to manual like he
doesn't bother with like
you know his life story or whatever i
mean there's a little bit of that but
it's really it really is just very
practical it's like look
i have found that when you're doing
performance reviews
you can talk to the people before doing
before giving them the review or after
you should always just do it after like
it's just stuff like that like it's just
these little things that are just like
just i have found that this is better
than that there's just a lot of you know
here another one that i it's just kind
of off the top of my head it's like when
somebody
tells you that they want to quit
drop everything you're doing
and if you don't want them to quit if
you want them to quit yeah let them quit
but otherwise drop everything you're
doing and make this your highest
priority because one of the main reasons
people quit is because they don't think
that you think they're important
it's just very very valuable advice like
that that is just super applicable
immediately to everything you're doing
so i i really think
you know that book has helped me a lot
to become a better manager
so we are going to
discuss
a number of facets of duolingo
and
new developments and so on before we get
to that
i asked a number of questions last time
that i think you may have new answers to
so i'm going to
just
ask those think there are four laced in
front of me and then we'll we'll zig and
zag back
into duolingo related things so the
first is
what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments
you've ever made that could be an
investment of money time
energy
pick your currency ah well i mean yeah
the easy answer for that is is duolingo
although i mean i've been at this for so
long that it's it was not an easy
investment yeah i mean obviously it has
has been very good
you know i'll give a counter-intuitive
one that has really helped me
i'll say it's a weird one
i have an aging mother
and i think a lot of people my age have
aging parents
i used to worry a lot about her
because she
used to live in guatemala and you know
guatemala is a dangerous place and i'm
like she she's she's pretty old i mean
she had me at an old age she had she had
me at age 42 so she's she's 85. and she
used to drive still in guatemala and it
was like this whole thing a lot of my
mental energy was it's not 80 percent of
my mental energy but it was a
significant fraction of my mental energy
was just worrying that she was okay
and
the investment that i did is
she moved in with me
and it's a weird thing i mean my house
is large enough that this is fine we get
along well and everything
but i feel so much better about it i
mean i'm just like now i'm not worried
about her she's she's there she's kind
of she's she's thriving and
she essentially keeps to herself it's
not like she bothers me all that much
but i just i'm just not worried about it
yeah and that this has made me
why
i freed up i don't know
call it four percent of my mental energy
that i was spending on that uh i it's
freed up and i just have more time to
worry about other things all right the
next question is in the last five years
what new belief behavior habit has most
improved
your life and at the time
first conversation we had on the podcast
it was
starting duolingo in
pittsburgh uh so kind of a slightly
oblique answer to the question
but i'm wondering if you have a
different answer to that or an
additional answer to that now
well i think a personal one if we go on
the personal one kind of a habit that
has really changed my life in the last
few years is strength training
i used to always kind of just do cardio
to work out and that was the main thing
but one thing that happened is i was
i don't know the year maybe 2017 in
january first of all
i don't love the winter in the
northeastern united states i am from
guatemala i'm not used to this this
makes no sense
how could you have a place where people
just die outside if they don't do
anything it's kind of ridiculous but
anyways i don't love the winter it was
january
i was not having a kind of a great
january i also got sick i had some sort
of like a flu and it was like
i was not doing super well
and i went to the office finally after
all this and i guess i looked
i didn't look so good i guess and
somebody that worked at the office
who's worked with us for a very long
time
dennis looked at me and he's like
luis
you need gary
uh and i'm like i know what you're
talking about
he's like
all right what are you doing tomorrow at
6 30 a.m i'm like nothing gary will show
up
anyways turns out gary shows up
gary is he was his personal trainer
dennis's personal trainer gary is kind
of a
he's quite a personality he he used to
be the strength trainer for the
pittsburgh steelers
and then the strength trainer for
university of pittsburgh basketball team
and it's just kind of and and now he
just has this roster of clients of like
all these rich people from pittsburgh
who are not athletes certainly i was not
an athlete and gary shows up and he's
like all right
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna make you
stronger
and he gives you some weights and and
then he laughs at how weak you are he
like laughs
i'm like what are you supposed to make
me feel good he's like oh my god
you can't even do like whatever 40 pound
dumbbells for bench plus what are you
doing
yeah and so he laughs at you and i've
been with him since like 2017.
it has really changed my life
i used to have all kinds of aches and
pains no longer
it turns out you know if you start i you
know a lot more about this than me but i
think if you start working out doing
straight strength training
after age call it 35 or so it's pretty
hard to build big muscle so it's not
like i've built humongous muscle but but
i just i'm just a lot healthier and
certainly a lot stronger
and so this has really changed my life
so gary gary's awesome
big big fan
wow i guess dennis dennis deserves some
significant thanks too oh dennis is also
awesome just taking the initiative no he
really he just looked at me and i i must
have looked like hell he just looked at
me he's like you need gary
[Laughter]
enough said not gonna elaborate yeah
uh how many times per week do you do
resistance training now three times a
week
three times a week
all right
we'll give this a shot we'll see if this
question goes anywhere and then we're
gonna
kind of zoom back
to
duolingo
and related topics what purchase of 100
or less has most positively impacted
your life
in recent memory easy and of course
listeners love specifics easy yeah easy
an electric toothbrush
ah i got the oral b io this
changes your life i mean it just you
can't go back yeah you can go back and
i'll tell you
when i started dating my current
significant other
one of the first few things that i did
was i i saw that she was kind of
slumming it with like a
regular toothbrush so one of the first i
just i just on amazon ordered her my
first gift to her was
an electric toothbrush
and
she said to this day
we've been together for longer i've
given her significantly more expensive
gifts to this day best gift i've ever
given her
it really just changes your life yeah if
you're not brushing with an electric
toothbrush you're doing it wrong
you know i i didn't expect this to come
up in this conversation but
i'm going to
i'm going to plus one that and mention
that i recently went to a new dentist
very highly recommended by a separate
doctor i work with apparently top of the
top as far as dentists go i was nervous
to go because i had not been to a
dentist since covid uh now this is
probably flashing back a common thing
yeah common common so i was terrified
that it was just going to be a
complete you know warfield of of issues
but it was mostly fine
but the point he made to me was
with his recommendations he said number
one you need to use
an electric toothbrush of some type
because it will prevent you
from applying too much pressure
and there are other benefits to it but i
apparently
brush my teeth like i'm trying to take
you know old grout off tile or something
and i just destroy my gums and it's not
that i'm trying to push really strongly
but i do nonetheless and i end up with
bleeding gums and all of this nonsense
and since using an electric toothbrush
as far as that problem goes problem
solved so
it's one of those where you're like just
don't realize because people had told me
this before but you just don't realize
how much you change your life i know
there's similar one it's not a hundred
dollars but it is it is
really life-changing is it japanese
toilet okay did you get the full
japanese toilet i did okay got it i got
the full total japanese toilet this
again more than 100 bucks but
life-changing
now it does cause a problem which is i
now
really
it's not like i can't really don't like
going to the bathroom anywhere about my
house
it's just a significantly better
experience
all right for people who are who may be
curious
i know i have a couple of friends who
are obsessed with with toto toilets do
you have a specific model can you recall
which which you decided on
yes it's called neorest neo rest toto
neo rest and it is hold on it is a
specific one total nearest nx1
let me tell you obviously the main
feature is that it uses kind of like the
bidet feature where it cleans you with
water which after you start thinking
about it it is barbaric that people in
the united states and most western
countries do not use water to clean
themselves
it really is after you think about it
well i like that i like the adjective
i'm a fan just think about this i mean
if you were to touch with your finger
some cow poop
yeah would you not wash your hands with
water like would you just use a towel to
like no you wouldn't because you would
feel like it's still dirty think about
that anyways so it obviously has that
better feature but it has all kinds of
other stuff including like white noise
so that
you know other people can hear you like
it just
it has features it is good
all right so
now let me give an alternative here
because i i'm guessing that that the
the neo this particular model is i mean
it's probably
at least a few thousand dollars yeah
it's not cheap i will give people an
alternative if they want somewhere
between
the bugatti of toilets and the barbaric
practice that you've already outlined
you can get and actually i was given as
a gift
a washlet toto seat so it effectively
replaces your toilet seat on your
pre-existing toilet and it's a few
hundred dollars you plug it into a wall
and it has a lot of the same features so
i'll just mention yes it does it is
pleasant to use and
you know i
never thought i would have a japanese
toilet or
i suppose a hybrid japanese toilet which
i have now
but when i was in japan when i was 15
there's some basic features i mean when
it is freezing and it get it gets cold
in certain parts of japan warmer yeah
when it's freezing and you go in and you
sit down and it's warm yes that has a
material impact on your day-to-day
experience
but see this is the thing about toilet
and the toothbrush i mean the thing is
these are things that you do every
single day
it's like also spending money on a good
mattress like it matters like these are
things that are just you just do it
every day and uh you know i understand
some of these things are can can be
pricey but i would not skimp too much on
things that you do every day
you know you mentioned the mattress i
will also plus one that we can get out
of the domestic
objects category but
when i was i spent a little bit of time
in panama in 2005
and got to stay with this lovely couple
and the
the matriarch of the family is
this this mother i got i wish i could
remember her name she was
really an incredible woman very smart
and she and she said to me it still
stuck with me she said
there are two things you should invest
in
make sure you invest to the extent that
you can she didn't caveat that but she
said make sure you invest in your bed
and your shoes because if you're not in
one you're gonna be in the other and i
was like haha
that's good advice makes a lot of sense
that's really good it makes a lot of
sense yeah and you know mattresses can
be expensive but you don't have to go
super nuts yeah
just don't buy the 50 mattress like that
probably you shouldn't do that it makes
a difference
and if your bed is i'll i'll offer
another hybrid option i
didn't realize i had so many opinions on
all these devices
yes yes if you're if let's just say you
can't afford to get a new mattress and
the mattress is iffy pillow top really
helps get a good pillow top
and
it will make
it will make a difference makes it makes
a huge difference and if you can't
afford that get a better pillow this is
another thing oh yeah and
i'll put a few i'll put a few pillow
options in the
in the show notes because i do have
opinions on pillows i don't test there's
some people who are like i've tested 10
mail mattresses this year i'm like i
don't have the time for that no but i
will test pillows
much easier
you know the other thing i don't know
much about i was recently reading
about the history of beds
and you know this is a few hundred years
ago not that long ago most people didn't
have a bed yeah like people slept on
like a bunch of clothes basically like
they would just kind of pile up some
clothes
and that's where they slept that's like
beds were just piles of clothes
wow
how far we've come when people
read a little history you realize
a lot of improvements have been made
all right let's let's go from indoor to
outdoor
and
i have your last answer here if you
could have a gigantic billboard anywhere
with anything on it this is
metaphorically speaking
getting a message out assuming people
would understand it right
let's just take that as assumed what
would it say and why it could be a few
words paragraph could be an image could
be anything your answer last time was it
would be a billboard right across the
street from google
google's office here in pittsburgh that
would say we at duolingo are hiring and
yes we can match your salary so
[Music]
do you have any new possible answers to
that question
yeah i think the word has gotten out a
lot more about duolingo hiring and we
get a lot of inbound applicants where i
think i don't think that billboard is as
necessary anymore
by the way we did have a billboard this
is not the one that we do but we did
have a billboard that was pretty
successful
in san francisco
that said that was for duolingo that
said
working tech
own a house move to pittsburgh
or something like that that's clever and
it got us a good number of employees it
really actually worked with people are
like ah
and it turns out if you move to
pittsburgh with a tech salary which
basically our salaries are the same as
what you would have in you know silicon
valley
you can own a pretty nice house
work in tech own a house
what was it what was the last move to
pittsburgh
[Laughter]
that's great you know what that reminds
me of is
that that it really covers a lot and
tells a whole story
in very short form i don't think you've
ever heard the uh
the story in six words by hemingway for
sale baby shoes never worn it's kind of
makes me think oh wow yeah your
billboard yeah incredible yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know what i would do now i
mean probably something silly i mean i
don't know if you've seen all the
duolingo memes
with the owl trying to kidnap your
family and stuff like that i have not
well they're they're pretty popular
they're pretty popular on tick tock
basically saying you know the idea is
that our are our notifications
can be pretty passive aggressive so for
example we have a notification on the
app that if you we send you a
notification every day to remind you to
practice
but if you don't practice for five days
we stop sending you notifications
at some point it occurred to us that we
could have a notification that said when
we stop we actually should tell you to
stop that we're stopping as in we should
be nice and tell you hey we're stopping
so we the last notification we send
before we stop is hey these
notifications don't seem to be working
we're going to stop sending them for now
and uh it comes from the owl and a lot
of people consider this a very passive
aggressive by the way this notification
gets people to come back a lot because
they feel bad they're like oh my god i'm
not giving up on on my spanish or my
french or whatever so it gets people to
come back quite a bit
but that
that notification has really gotten all
kinds of people to talk more and more
about our notifications
and there's a whole persona that has
evolved not by us it's like the internet
has evolved a whole persona for our owl
that it kidnaps your family if you're
not learning spanish
and there's a number of of kind of tag
lines that they have that the owl would
say so for example one is spanish or
vanish
or
french or the trench
japanese or your niece
like they just come up with a lot of
these so i would just have a fun
billboard that just at spanish or vanish
spanish or vanish you know sometimes
it's the little things that get people
talking i'll i'll just we won't get into
it right now but people should google
derrick sivers s-i-v-e-r-s cd baby that
was his company at the time
email
it's a confirmation email that they
would
send out when orders came in it was an
automated email so people can just
search derek siver's cd baby email we'll
put in the show notes
as well all right coming back to
present day
i have notes in front of me one of which
is
related to mission and mission steering
business decisions
when i think many people including
myself sometimes hear mission we're like
oh boy here we go this is going to be
like
some type of thing on a wall in office
space or some type of kind of lead with
integrity type thing from a ge type of
company where you're like all right well
what does that mean and does that really
have an impact on people on a day-to-day
basis what do you mean when you talk
about
mission
yeah so i feel similarly to you i'm
distrustful when people say that
it is interesting that at duolingo i
think it really has to do with this
first group of employees that we talked
about before that were like pretty big
zealots on our mission
that we really
most every decision that we make at
duolingo is very mission oriented and
our mission you know there's a statement
of the mission that sounds that sounds
good but and it's i'll say the statement
but i'll kind of explain it more so this
statement is to develop the best
education in the world and make it
universally available the real driving
forces we want to make sure that anybody
who wants to learn can do so
now
we're not out there giving people phones
or anything like that we we do assume
that you have
some sort of smart device
and the reason for that assumption is
that's just the world is going that way
these days you can get an android device
for 30 bucks
so it is kind of going that way we we
make sure that our app works on very low
end android devices for example but we
just we really want to make sure that
anybody who wants to learn a language
well not languages but we're expanding
to teaching other things too but anybody
who wants to learn a language can do so
without having to pay us
and this matters to us
and
most of the decisions we make are
related to this but one of the things
that i think has really
affected my thinking and certainly
the company behavior
is we are all really big believers that
yeah the mission we like the mission and
it's great we're all really big
believers that that mission is actually
well aligned with the long-term success
of our company
as as a business entity so as a as an
actual money-making publicly traded
company it is aligned with a long-term
success and let me kind of explain you
know for example
we could say tomorrow you know what
screw it
you have to pay to use duolingo
my guess is we would not no my guess i'm
pretty sure we would make a lot more
money if we did them
our number of users would go down
but
a good number of them would also pay us
and we would make a lot more money and
next quarter would be an amazing quarter
for us like we would i i
it would be an amazing quarter for us i
don't know the off the top of my head
but our revenue probably would 10x or
some crazy number in like one quarter
would just go nuts
however
what that would do is it would
completely stifle our growth
because the way duolingo has grown is
through word of mouth
we have all these people who use us for
free they don't pay us we make some
money off them from the ads but you know
most of our money comes from our
subscription
but what's really useful about all these
people that use us is the users they
have a good experience and they tell
their friends
and the vast majority of our users
i mean really the overwhelming majority
of our users when you ask them how you
know how did you find out about duolingo
it's like a friend told me or like my my
significant other told me or whatever
it's basically word of mouth
and and i really do believe that having
a really great free user experience it's
what's best for the business in the long
run
again not next quarter but if you take
the long view which we are dueling i
mean we've been at this for 10 years i'm
i'm going to stick around duolingo
probably forever i mean i really love
working here etc
so my view now is a long-term view i
mean i'm here thinking about the next 10
years the next 20 years etc and i really
think that
if we do the right thing for our users
in terms of like actually being able to
learn a language really well
and without having to pay us
that is actually what's going to
optimize our revenue in the long term so
i believe that i think most everybody in
the company believes that and i think
that
that alignment has made it so that a lot
of decisions are a lot easier because we
do hire a bunch of people who are like
uh what the hell you talking about
mission like you know this is people who
went to like whatever business school
and everything's like well i'm just here
to make money
so we do hire some such people but i
think once they understand that we
really it's not like we don't want to
make money it's not like we you know we
really are big believers that there's
real long-term alignment here
i think that really
that aligns everybody
what
other ways
does the
long view
impact decision making so
maybe you could give another example or
two
as to how that informs
not just the culture but but how you
make
decisions
and you already mentioned one which
would be the
the decision to keep it
free for the majority of users versus
force a subscription upon everyone and
then have a short-term game for all of
these long-term sacrifices
can you think of any other ways in which
taking the longer view
affects decision making i'll tell you
another one that has worked out really
well for us but it has to do you know
one of the things about taking advice
from certain companies that i've learned
is
taking individual pieces of advice
sometimes doesn't work because they it
only works for that company in the
context of that company right totally we
have a very specific context which is
because again because our culture is
good because pittsburgh
is not quite silicon valley etcetera we
have low employee churn
if you see a silicon valley company a
lot of times i mean by the way silicon
valley is amazing these companies
operate really well
but
one of the things that is common in
silicon valley is people don't stay at
jobs for very long
and companies have become optimized for
that they are they're optimized for it
that's just
they're very good at operating excellent
companies when the assumption is that
people are going to stay there for two
three years
and they get really good at that
at duolingo people stay for much longer
than that people stay for a pretty long
time
and
where we take the long view in doing
things is in hiring
we
are really picky with hiring and and
it's because people stick around for a
long time that it really matters so it
matters that you know if they're gonna
be here for eight years
it matters
it's okay to wait a couple of months to
find somebody that is probably going to
be 20 better for this job than not
because overall yeah totally however if
you are a company where you know you
have pretty high churn
probably this is not as worthwhile so
it's just for us this has been a pretty
good thing for you know taking the long
view and hiring has been good for us
well i'd like to
ask more about that specifically so i i
am trying to get better at hiring myself
and
had some maybe beginner's luck where i i
did really well in the beginning had
people stick around for a long time but
have had
a couple of misses in the last few years
and it's been hard
yeah it does happen and it's been it's
been hard for me
to
really deconstruct the reasons for that
in a in a post-game
analysis although i do think that there
were probably
there was some
unnecessary rushing to the hiring
process so we talked in our last
conversation about
hiring and you mentioned that you've
learned how expensive hiring mistakes
can be no doubt you've learned that
more than once so you guys are very
strict in your interviews and you
describe the process i'd love to see if
this has changed and if it is different
for non-technical roles in 2016 it was
number one resume screen good gpa
internships and so on number two two
phone screens which includes problem
solving number three bringing remaining
candidates on site where they have four
different interviews some of which
involve more problem solving as well as
paired programming during which they fix
a bug so this
seems to be specific for
technical candidates
i'm wondering if you have anything to
add to this if you could maybe elaborate
on on what
taking your time
and looking for that extra 20
looks like and i suppose i'm most
interested in in non-technical roles
since i am not hiring for for real
technical capabilities but
anything you have to to say on any of
those points would be interesting
yeah that interview is pretty similar to
what we do now i think you know some the
specific actual questions may have
changed a little bit what we look for in
resumes may have changed a little bit
but it is a the overall is pretty
similar and that is for technical
technical hires
non-technical hires it really depends
you know that's that's another thing
about hiring i mean it really depends on
what your
what function you're hiring for so for
example designers
what matters a lot is their portfolio
and the portfolio is this magical thing
portfolios are amazing because within 30
seconds by looking at a portfolio you
can tell a lot like it's just you don't
even have to do all that much interview
or anything they just look at a
portfolio yep this is good
and the other beautiful thing about
portfolios by the way is that it's so
nice because
they're really good for diversity in
that you don't have to know this
person's name you don't have to know
what they look like you don't have to
know anything you don't it's just the
work speaks for itself yeah so this is
the beautiful thing about design but
that's very rare usually you don't
most fields don't have a thing like the
portfolio where you just look at it and
you're like this is it
so
you know i i think outside of these you
have to get really good at
interviewing and you got to figure out
there's a few things that really work
out
one is work product
so
whatever it is that they're supposed to
do you have them do some of that it
could be that they do it offline as in
like they don't have to do it in front
of you it could be like look in order to
apply you have to
you have to
write this thing or whatever it is you
can take your time just send it to us as
part of the application
work product is is really good i i think
that really tells you whether and it has
to be pretty close to what they're
supposed to do when when you hire them
so that's
that's really good i think there's
another one which is just kind of
general intelligence stuff which you may
or may not want to do
but there are some pretty simple kind of
there's this like three question iq test
that you can google for
which is just you know it's not going to
give you an exact precise you know with
just three questions you're not going to
be able to get an exact iq but basically
you know if people can solve this
all three of these questions
they're pretty good with cognitive
abilities
you may want to do that and then the
other one is just kind of more of these
behavioral interviews that you ask these
questions that you really do it does
make a difference for non-technical
stuff i mean things like talk about
a failure
tell me about a time you failed and the
types of things you're looking for is a
do they recognize that they have failed
like the wrong answer the the horrible
ones is this like failure not failure
like when they tell you like i just care
too much
yeah yeah or or like
it starts looking like a failure but
actually it was a home run you're like
no no no no
like a real failure and so you want to
understand that they understand when
they failed the other thing you want to
hear there is
did they
blame others or themselves
it's very telling when they tell you
about a failure it's a real failure but
they're like but you know what i knew
what to do the whole time
it's just my manager was dumb or
whatever like so that that's a very bad
sign that because look everybody's
failed and there's at least one instance
and usually many where it really was
your fault
i want to hear about that
not about how you always knew all along
and you're always right and it's just
your manager sucked or somebody else
because when you do end up hiring them
you know these are the type of people
that would probably blame everybody else
for their failures and you don't want
that
so there are these kind of behavioral
interviews that i think really work out
pretty well
so we do we do apply all of those but
you know one of the things that i have
learned a lot
is um and we we employ it at duolingo
when you are the hiring manager so the
person that's actually going to work
with them
and usually it's because you you're
hiring somebody because you have a need
you're like well i need a designer on my
team or i need whatever it is i need
this on my team and i have the need
you're extremely biased
towards hiring
yes
you're like look i just need to get this
done i just want to get it so one of the
things we do is ultimately at duolingo
the decisions are not by the hiring
manager our manager can have a lot of
input but there's somebody else that is
like
a lot of times that's me who's like
i understand you're in deep pain right
now and you need more you know another
person but this person does not pass our
bar
and it's not that i'm that good at the
bar
it's just that i'm a different person so
i make the same mistake when i'm hiring
from you know an executive or something
i have a bias towards hiring because i'm
like man i know i don't want to spend
more time looking for you know this
whatever our head of whatever
by the way we did this for our cfo our
chief financial officer we took a long
time and at some point i almost gave up
i'm like man i'll just take whoever like
it doesn't matter
we didn't do that i was lucky i was
lucky that we'd ended up i mean i had
spent about a year
looking for our cfo yeah it's a long
time
thank god we waited i mean we our cfo
maskaroop is amazing uh thank god we
waited but you know
in the middle there after i don't know
nine months or so i started faltering i
started being like
just take whoever
so it's not that i'm that good at
holding our bar but i'm very good at
holding a bar when it's not me
yeah that makes sense to me that's a big
big piece of advice have somebody else
hold the bar
okay so this is actually a very
opportune time to segue so the
two things i'm going to cover well i'm
going to cover that's not true the royal
eye that you are going to cover
that i'd love to explore are number one
how did you decide to go public when did
you decide it was the right time to
pursue that and the cfo may
they somehow be involved with that but
the
question after that is going to be
what's next
right new products you alluded to
something beyond
language learning so certainly i would
love to hear more about that but let's
begin with the going public question and
just how you
thought about that and made decisions
around it
and then
from there into new products new revenue
streams things like that
okay so first of all the idea of going
public for example last time we talked
you know i don't know exactly what was
going on six years ago in my head but
the idea of public going public i think
around then
just seems so
foreign so like that's never gonna
happen
i wasn't just not thinking about that
once we figured out our revenue and we
figured out that we could make a lot of
revenue the first time this really was
discussed was we were having a meeting
with one of our board members
his name is bing gordon and his bing is
like a legendary guy in silicon valley
very famous very famous says a lot of
crazy stuff
a lot of really good crazy stuff but
also sometimes it's like just really
crazy stuff
and you know he was just sitting there
and we were talking about our revenue
and he said look
you're going to make this much revenue
next year you're going to make that much
revenue the year after that and then
you're going to go public
and we were like what
are you just completely like really
you can do that you could just go public
that's like a thing and he's like yeah
why not
[Laughter]
and that's kind of where it clicked
and that's we know we're like okay maybe
and and we started thinking about it and
then i we when we got to the point we
were basically breaking even
which happened you know being talked
about that maybe the year after that we
were already breaking or we're roughly
breaking even i mean it was like it was
not exactly breaking we're pretty close
to breaking even we're like oh maybe we
should maybe we should consider going
public and the first step if you're
going to go public the first thing you
need is you need a cfo like this
maybe you can go public without a cfo
but uh seems like a really bad idea
don't do that
generally ill-advised
yes so step one is you need to see for a
cfo that actually knows how to take you
public
a lot of people give you advice that you
should hire a cfo that has taken a
company public
that is hard for many reasons
for one there's just not very many such
people
secondly
cfos turn out to be very highly paid
individuals
and when you go public you get paid a
lot as a cfo so what ends up happening
is a lot of these people who are cfos
who've taken a company public are just
very rich
and they don't want to work for you
anymore they're just like whatever i
have my house in the hamptons and that's
this is where i am and i'm just not
going to go work with you
so it's just a very limited pool of
people who have taken a company public
once
and so there's that and then we did
interview some some people and you know
they had good experience what we ended
up doing for cfo is not take somebody
who had taken a company public but you
know he obviously knew finance etc he
came from goldman sachs but we maximized
for
kind of
intelligence and grit
and and that was a really good move for
us and so that worked out for us quick
question so intelligence i can see how
you test for intelligence how do you
assess grit ah it's just you know i i
think a lot of it has to do from
references i mean this one
matt that we hired we we knew a few
people that knew him
and you know every there's a reference
we're just and they were true the thing
is they were truly they'll tell you like
oh mascarupa is like
the hardest working most
and also most honest guy i've ever met
and i'm like to me the words honest and
cfo just kind of don't go together that
much i don't i don't know if i just had
i was biased against that but then we
hired a guy that is like the most honest
guy like we call him sometimes some of
us call him the boy scout because he's
just like this guy is just kind of a
good guy
and so we hired a mat
and you know by the way the other thing
with matt is matt was going to be based
in new york right before covent we hired
matt
i don't know his first day was maybe a
month before covet before like it's
probably like february of 2020 or
something like that he was going to be
based in new york but we're
headquartered in pittsburgh we have an
office in new york with about 100 people
he was going to be in that office but he
knew he had to travel out to pittsburgh
on his first day he shows up with a
i don't know it had like 10 slides a
deck with his travel plans for the next
two years
he had
pie charts a fraction of time he was
gonna spend like in pittsburgh in new
york on the plane like it's all this
stuff that he had done like a massive
analysis like what a consultant would do
for some sort of analysis he's like this
is my travel schedule for the next two
years and i'm like
wow i i would have never done anything
like this but i see we hired the right
person
he must have spent hours and hours on
this and then poor guy kovit came and
then that travel plan went down the
drain and
just didn't have to travel
but anyways you hire cfo that's kind of
the first thing and then
and then
for me i think what really mattered was
is our revenue and this seems to be like
what matters the most is our revenue
predictable is our finances predictable
if your finances are not predictable you
should not go public you're going to
have a real bad time
so you know you want to know that your
finances are predictable and by
predictable i mean
i've learned
you need to be able to predict your
finances with you know a year out
and be like three percent away
so this is a pretty good prediction that
you have to pretty good forecasting so
you have to do that
and you have to have a path to real
profitability that's the other thing
if you don't have either of those i
would say
i i would not go public uh you just had
a really bad time
the other thing to say about having gone
public i'm very happy we did
the company operates better
i think of it as like you know when
nobody visits you in your house you kind
of don't have to clean all that much
like it's not a very clean house if
nobody ever visits you you're like you
kind of live like a slob it's like but
if there's gonna be a visit coming
you're like oh [ __ ] i gotta clean up
once a quarter
well it's not once a quarter because now
we're like constant scrutiny but but by
basically i think what happened is once
the process of going public
forced us to do all these things much
better like there were all these
processes that were like they were just
not well set up as a process or like we
may not even have had a process and it's
like no we're gonna go public now now we
have to have a process now so at this
point our house is pretty clean because
we get visits all the time
and i think that the thing about living
in a clean house is you feel good about
it yeah you know it's just kind of
better and so i'm very happy that we
went public
yeah you know i just want to say also to
folks who may be listening and have a
small business and they're like i'm
never going public this isn't relevant
to me what i would say is
and there are there are books that you
can read that i think are
are interesting for as a thought
exercise at the very least there's a
book called built to sell i think the
author's name is john warlow
and if someone wants to improve their
own business let's just say it's a
smaller business with five employees
pretend like you're gonna sell it
right pretend like you're gonna sell it
in 12 months and
you will go through you renovate the
bathroom is what you're saying yeah
you're gonna renovate the bathroom
you're gonna realize like oh yeah the
duct tape on that part of the plumbing
no no one's going to buy that that's not
going to pass the inspection so we're
going to have to fix that
and
you can go through a very similar house
cleaning process where you build systems
you remove yourself as a bottleneck for
certain
decisions and so on that can be hugely
hugely beneficial so i'll just mention
the parallels
there what have been the biggest
challenges
of being public
yeah or being a publicly i'd want to
make it too abstract i mean they're the
challenges of being a publicly traded
company i'm just wondering being the ceo
of a publicly traded company
a lot of people assumed that my job was
going to change a lot
it hasn't
and the other thing is we worked really
hard to make sure that our culture
didn't change a lot if you ask a random
which i have if you ask a random
duolingo employee how does it feel
before and after they'll tell you very
little changed
there's a couple of things you know you
can't really give forward-looking
statements as much right where you can't
say like well next year we're gonna make
this much revenue or whatever just don't
do that
stuff like that but it's minor i would
say and i think my job in particular
the only real change is now i have to
spend
well i have a deal with our head of
investment relations
i only i have to spend 12 hours a
quarter
on talking to investors or analysts
and so that's that
the reason i have this deal is you can
spend 100 of your time doing that and
for sure i love talking to investors and
analysts love talking to them but it's
just you can't run a company when you
spend 100 of your time talking to them
you just actually just can't do that
so i give her 12 hours a quarter how did
you settle on 12 hours i'm just so
curious is that one hour a week no we
negotiated we negotiated i started with
five she's like you can't do that and
she's like how about 20. i'm like in the
end we just settled on on 12
that's about the biggest change i don't
think there's there's much else i guess
i have to write you don't have to do
this by the way i just learned i was
very clueless before going public about
what it really meant to be a publicly
traded company one of the things i i
recently learned is you don't have to
have earnings calls or shareholder
letters you don't have to do this
i thought you did and we do them we do
them every quarter turns out you don't
this is not a legal requirement of any
kind
but it's probably a good idea to do it
so anyways the other thing i have to
write a shareholder letter we do
shareholder letters and i have to do
that every quarter but other than that
it's been it's been good i mean we're
fortunate that
you know the stock market has been
pretty choppy
we're fortunate that our stock has held
up pretty well
there are some companies for whom you
know they're like down 90 from when they
went public or something like that that
must be very tough
we're fortunate that that's just not the
case yeah that's when the activists
start circling in the waters yeah
yeah you know it's fortunate but i also
think
the thing we made sure of is we both had
a highly forecastable business
and a good path to good profitability
i think if you have those two
you're gonna do okay i think it's you
know last year in particular you saw a
number of companies that were
you know either not very forecastable or
just kind of did not care at all about
profitability and i think
in today's climate that's just not so
great yeah yeah that's uh sort of tying
an r behind your back
when you get into the boxing ring like
you might win you might but it does make
it a little more challenging
and you know what else does not help i
don't know if you've watched this show
we crashed which by the way is an
excellent show yes the story of wework
yeah i saw episode one actually at south
by southwest i love that show but you
know one of the things that does not
help is
investment bankers will tell you what
you want to hear
you're they're supposed to be like you
know there to coach you but they make
money if you go public
and they make a ton of money if you go
public so
it is common that they'll tell you yeah
of course you're ready to go public of
course yeah and i just don't think they
are as
brutally honest as they should be
in that respect
yeah well you know it's like uh
the
old buffetism don't ask a barber if you
need a haircut
being
being aware of the incentives involved
is important
yeah which is also you know it could be
true for reward it could be true for
punishment or pain as you're mentioning
earlier with hiring right if you are in
the hot seat and you are
facing
the consequences of a lack of a hire you
are going to be strongly incentivized
and you might use motivated reasoning to
push for a faster higher than you should
yes and and this is the crazy thing
about that is that even if you're not
you may not even be malicious like i'm
not saying that it's just it's just
these incentives work that way like
i'm not saying the investment backers
are even malicious or anything they're
just like in their way of viewing the
world they're like yeah it's good for
you to go public just yeah it's just
human nature
all right looking towards the future new
products revenue streams
what's coming
yeah we're very excited by this
so historically duolingo has been
language learning
you know that's the thing we teach
languages by now we're we're the largest
way to learn languages in the world
we're you know with most popular than
than any other way to learn languages
including public school systems
so
that's awesome but you know our mission
has always been
more general just kind of we really like
all of education we started with
language learning so we're starting to
expand to other things
we've launched already a literacy app
that's different from language learning
in that it's your native language you
just need to learn how to read
so this is an app for kids
right now it's only in english it's dual
lingo abc
that teaches kids
when we were working on it we thought
kids three to six
turns out kids get
there's like a downward pressure for
learning how to read
earlier and earlier so some of our top
users for the app are actually two
so there's these kids that are h2 that
are learning how to read on our app
which i'm like i don't even think i knew
how to walk when i was two i don't know
but somehow these kids are learning how
to read at h2 with with the app so we
started with that we're working on a
math app that is going to come out this
year where the idea is you're going to
be able to learn some math we're
starting with elementary school math
so like and not first grade so not
counting but we're starting with kind of
basic arithmetic
and fractions and stuff like that
one of the interesting things about that
is that
well the reason we're starting with
elementary school math is because that's
kind of where you start seeing a
divergence in people who are
quote-unquote good at math versus not
right around when you have to learn kind
of multiplication and division and stuff
like that so we want to get to kids then
that's one thing but there's another
thing and i think it's going to be for
the growth of the app
it's actually pretty fun for adults
in that
we've made it into it feels a lot like a
game like like dueling i mean i have the
app on my phone it feels a lot like a
game and this you know third to fifth
grade math is right at the level where
adults
find it challenging
but doable so if we were to give adults
like most of those like ninth grade math
did i can't do it like most of them like
that's too hard but if you're giving
like adults you know some
fraction problems or
multiplication or stuff like that
it's kind of like brain training
so we actually think this app is going
to grow both for students who are kind
of elementary school students but also
kind of people who just want to get a
little better at math
and do some brain training kind of more
adults and so the app is going to kind
of cater to both
and we're very excited by that and again
it's you know i have a phd in computer
science you would think that i am good
at math but i'm i'm loving kind of basic
multiplication here where
i'm not learning it i'm just it's just
kind of everyday kind of brain training
so i'm we're very very excited by that
project okay so the math is going to
launch in 2022. i
i am very much looking forward to that
and it's timely for me it's been on my
brain and if you can let
just allow me to be a little
self-indulgent and talk for a second
it's it's a bit a bit later in my life
trajectory but i in ninth grade
i had a i was very good at math and i
had a math teacher who just brutalized
the male students in the class i don't
know why she did this but she she just
really had an axe to grind and basically
all of
the
male cohort in that class stopped taking
math
uh myself included and my brother had
the opposite experience and ended up
with a phd in statistics and is
about as qui heavy as you can imagine he
had a very very good teacher and i've
always had on some level i consider
myself numerate but in a very basic way
and i've wanted to
rekindle some of those capabilities or
at least the interest in math and
concurrent with that
one of my
close friend's closest friends
is about to go to grad school and will
need to take
an intro
to stats
class but
this friend also
stopped math quite early didn't have the
support structure that i did so for her
it was probably
in the earlier elementary school years
so i've been thinking a lot about this
and you know how do you make it not just
learnable but
hopefully on some level interesting and
enjoyable and rewarding so i've been
looking at there's a i can't i can't
remember his name there's a professor or
who was it harvey mudd who developed a
book called mathematics yeah i've heard
of that one yeah yeah and i feel like
you know some of those techniques might
be considered like cheap tricks but i i
do find that it is very rewarding if you
teach someone how to say multiply double
digit numbers by 11 and it's a trick
sure it doesn't apply to 12 but
but it shows people that they can do
something they thought they couldn't do
so i'm very excited to see the math
program
the other thing that you know we've
learned that duolingo is what we did
with the original duolingo app the
language learning app is we got really
good at
getting you to repeat stuff over and
over again and you know the way you
learn a language is by a lot of
repetition
and i really believe this to be true
also of kind of the type of elementary
school math and so one of the things
that's awesome about this product is
that it really is fun and you
we've made it so that repeating these
multiplications or whatever is actually
fun
because you know you get all these kind
of this progress bars and points and
stuff like that and it just kind of
feels fun and then you're doing exactly
what you're supposed to be doing the way
you get much better at this math is by
repeating it 10 000 times this just
that's just how you get better at it
so
is there anything else that that you
have coming that you'd like to talk
about or anything else that you're
working on that you're particularly
excited about
the thing that i'm really excited about
in addition to all these things is a
project that we're not
people in the us don't know us so much
for this project but it's a pretty
successful and amazing project it's
called the duolingo english test
so what it is is a standardized english
proficiency exam so basically you go
there you take a test for call it 30
minutes 30 to 45 minutes and at the end
you get a score from zero to 160 about
how good your english is that's it
that's the product
it turns out that doing this is pretty
necessary in most countries in the world
again not that necessary in the us
because everybody speaks english but
if you want to get a work visa in the uk
you have to take a standardized english
exam
if you want to come to college in the us
from an english-speaking country you
have to take a standardized english exam
if you want to get promoted in japan in
most jobs you have to take a
standardized english exam
so there's all these reasons for taking
these and
we made our own test
the reason we made our own tests is
because before our test you had to these
all these standardized english tests you
had to go to a physical testing center
to take them yeah to like you know like
actually go somewhere and they got a
paper test etc
we thought that was ridiculous so we
made our own that you can take it online
and it's been really really
successful and a really rewarding
project because
what this has done so by now our test is
is now accepted for example by 4 200
academic programs in the world so if you
want to apply to most universities in
the usa if you want to apply to mit or
stanford they accept our test as proof
of english proficiency
so this is great but the reason this has
been so rewarding is that we're getting
all these people to take this test that
simply could not take a standardized
english proficiency exam before
people who live far away from cities
they just couldn't
or
you know it turned out that in the
democratic republic of congo there was
just no way to take a standardized
english test it just couldn't so if you
were there and you wanted to apply to a
place like
you know a u.s university you had to fly
somewhere
to actually take the test which is kind
of ridiculous so it's been very
rewarding to do this and i'm very
excited by this project because
first of all we keep getting more and
more acceptance on it
and so
the hope is that this will become the
standard for english proficiency so what
we're hoping to do and not just for
english we're hoping to do it for every
every language out there at least the
big languages so we're hoping to change
so that when somebody asks you how much
french do you know or how much english
do you know we want the answer to be oh
i am a duolingo 65
or i'm a dueling on 90. that's what we
want the answer to be that's not true
today but that's what we want and and it
would be a lot better because for
example the most common answers for how
much french you know are one i took four
years of high school french which
doesn't answer anything
the other one is i'm intermediate which
is like also like um what the hell does
that even mean
so we really want people to say i'm a
dual length 65 in french our approach
for this is going to be the test is one
side which gives it our score legitimacy
look that score is good enough for you
to get into you know mit or duke or
whatever that's good
and then we don't have that yet but
we're going to start putting that score
in the app we're going to start putting
an estimated score of the dual and go
english test or the dual angle spanish
test once we have a spanish we don't yet
have a spanish test
we're going to start putting in the app
that gives it scale so pretty soon
literally hundreds of millions of people
are going to have an estimated score
and the hope is that people start
putting in their resume etc etc and i
think if we're able to do that
this will be
not only good for the world but also for
the company that will be a very
defensible position because we kind of
own the the scale so i'm very excited by
that
i want to share a little bit of back
story
and then i want to ask a question about
how you actually do this testing
so the back story that i wanted to share
briefly is that
you're very good at catching cheaters
you have a history of catching cheaters
so i i don't want to spend too much time
on this but i'll just give a quick recap
so
you have taught at carnegie mellon and
my recollection this is this is
shorthand here based on notes i have but
you tell students they were not to
google certain answers for specific
homework assignments then you would
create honeypot websites with the
answers to homework questions the
websites would record ip addresses then
you would call out the cheaters and tell
the class if they confessed they would
simply get a zero but if
if he meaning you had to do the work of
figuring out who it was you would report
them and they got so scared of your
tricks that they eventually all stopped
cheating so you have a history of
catching people who are trying to game
the system
in the case of remote
aptitude testing
for english
are you still using the the front-facing
camera and microphone on a phone or how
do you set it up such that it is hard to
game the system yeah we've spent a lot
of effort to make sure that is one of
the hardest things you you have to one
of the hardest problems you have to
solve if you are testing
some like an english proficiency for
high-stakes tests
and this by the way that's the reason
why they forced people to go to testing
centers because they wanted to make sure
they weren't cheating yeah
it turns out we are able to solve this
and we just use a number of tricks i
mean obviously we turn on the
front-facing camera of the device right
now the test only works on on computers
we did not do it for phones um so you
have to take it on a computer
front-facing camera the device we have a
real human watch you do the test
we also have artificial intelligence
that kind of looks at where you're
looking and that turns out to be really
powerful
when you
are taking a test
it is very predictable where you're
going to be looking i mean you basically
on the screen there is the area that has
the question we need to see that you
actually went and read that
and you know your eyes scan that then
you're probably going to be looking
where you're typing etc so you can
pretty well tell that that is actually
the person taking the test as opposed to
being taken by somebody else we also do
all kinds of other things i mean we
record all the ambient noise we also
lock down your computer as in like you
have to download an app that that kind
of turns off everything in your computer
and also tells us whether your computer
is connected to external devices whether
you have all kinds of you know like for
example some some headphones that are
telling you the answer or whatever so
a lot of that we do a lot of that and
and the way we know we catch cheaters
is that we actually have a program where
we pay people to try to cheat and we see
whether they're successful or not that's
that's great yeah you red team your own
system yeah we do and that's been really
good and you know every now and then
they're able to find something that kind
of passes through and then we patch it
and i'll tell you
even though
this is kind of the new technology and
everything and and people would say like
ah but it's still computers maybe maybe
they're doing something weird it's a
hell of a lot easier to cheat
in offline kind of testing centers
because the way people cheat in these
offline testing centers is so easy and
it's as follows most of these testing
centers are in developing countries
the person who is
the attendant
the person who works at the testing
center is not a highly paid employee in
a developing country
turns out non-highly paid employees in
developing countries will take a hundred
bucks bribe for
well almost anything
so this is this is how you cheat there
and it's actually very this is low low
fidelity old school cheating which is
like here's 100 bucks
just say that i took the test but
actually here's my friend who actually
speaks english let them take the test
thanks bye
so that is how people cheat people
actually cheat that way you cannot cheat
that way with our tests because you
cannot see who's proctoring you you just
you can't you can't communicate with
them etc so
we feel pretty good about the the
anti-testing mechanics here
yeah i'm glad i asked that that covered
a lot more than than i expected
we would cover do you still eat greek
yogurt for breakfast at least last time
we spoke you did the same breakfast for
two to three years as well as the as an
example of one decision that removes a
thousand decisions or have you have you
decided to swap in a new breakfast for
yourself i swapped in i'm very similar
but i just do now it's just a little jug
of muscle milk because my trainer gary
on his first date gary's a funny guy he
only cares about strength he said let's
have the nutrition conversation i'm like
okay and he said drink muscle milk
and then i'm like anything else he's
like nope
just drink muscle milk thanks
that was his nutrition conversation
good good talk
i was hoping he'd be like well you know
eat this type of whatever vegetable and
this after that nothing he's just like
just drink some muscle milk
so it's what i do for breakfast hey
keeps it simple
daily have it yep just like brushing
your teeth
yeah all right two more questions maybe
three and then we can bring this to a
close and land the plan all right so
next question
is
a more generalized what advice would you
give to a smart driven say college
student could you could pick a different
age about to enter the real world
and secondarily if you want to take a
stab at this you know what advice should
they ignore
you know for me the biggest advice is
i mean it depends on what you want you
want to get a job you want to work you
want to work or do you want to just play
video games if you want to play video
games go play video games whatever
that's fine
but if you actually want to get a job
i would say the most important thing is
find a way to become useful you know i
am getting older and i don't know if
it's just always people talking about
the younger generations this way but a
lot of times a lot of kind of the you
know the gen z's it used to be even
millennials but the gen z's
you know they show up and they're like
what are you gonna do for me and uh
it's like well can you do this no no i
don't i don't like that that's not a
good learning opportunity for me
or like you hired me to be a software
engineer i'm not going to do that's not
my job i'm not going to do that that's
not my job
the attitude of just
finding a way to become useful gets you
a lot farther yeah certainly at dualingo
but i think in most places in life where
it's just like oh you need me to do this
this is what's actually needed yeah i'll
do it i'm pretty smart i'll figure it
out i'll do it
and now obviously you know if you're
hard to be a software engineer you
should not go and like build a building
because you don't even know how to do
that but just kind of just find ways to
become useful and
crucial for the company will get you
a lot more perks and promotions than
having this attitude of like
you know what are you gonna do for me
yeah
that's just my sense and i see that a
lot of the what are you gonna do for me
attitude
yeah you know just to add to that
the opposite would be something like
and i think i'm getting this right it's
a friend of mine kelly starrett very
well known performance coach pt has
written many books works with tons of
professional athletes the top
tier of
of elite military
and he also happened to be
i would i would say he might disagree
but olympic level whitewater kayaker for
a period of time and i went on the
i went on a river trip with him and he
mentioned to everybody as
this priming talk as part of this
orientation he said you know there are
really four words
that will make the biggest difference in
this trip and it's how can i help he's
just like everybody should ask that
and if you just i mean it's it seems so
rudimentary but
i would agree with you and man if you
just take that attitude like you're on a
river trip how can i help if you've got
some extra time or slack
it really will
distinguish you it really does
it is amazing i mean i see it we do you
know of course we hire a lot of people
and everybody we hire is pretty awesome
but the ones that have more of this
attitude
just get farther in life yeah i just
because they're just there they're like
how can i help i just i just need to
help
we have a i have a story of it's kind of
two separate employees
this is kind of early duolingo where we
didn't have a blog we of course now have
a blog for stuff
one just kept complaining we didn't have
a blog he's like i can't believe i have
a blog
why don't we have a blog
it's ridiculous we don't have a blog but
never did anything another one started
and they just said
i noticed we don't have a blog so i
started one
and here it's linked to the website
that is the attitude that helps a lot
more than
just being like i can't believe we don't
have a blog how about you do something
about it
[Laughter]
okay last
question for me
and then there's just a closing question
if there's anything else you'd like to
add say or direct the listeners to
in any way
in the last handful of years
what have you become better at saying no
to could be distractions invitations
anything are there any new realizations
or approaches that have have helped you
to
say no to more maybe that's not even a
problem you have but i figured i would
ask
no i have a problem saying no and i've
definitely become better at saying no
you know in some cases i just don't have
the time but it is a problem i mean the
promise i'm a people pleaser like i want
to please the people in front of me
whoever they are sometimes even if they
are a random stranger emailing me some
stuff i still i'm a people pleaser so
this is not that new but it is a big
trick that i learned a little while ago
specifically for invitations and stuff
like that which is
i used to say yes to an invitation to
like give a talk
next year
just go give a talk next year and i used
to say yes because i thought next year i
won't be that busy
or whatever like and just if you change
your framing whenever somebody asks you
to do something a long time from now
change the framing and say what if it
was tomorrow
would you want to do this or not
almost invariably the answer is no i
definitely don't want to do this
tomorrow
and then you should answer based on that
yeah and i think that has helped me say
no to a lot of things where you just say
like okay because
it's not necessarily a trick that people
use although sometimes maybe it is a
trick but
you know when you i just get asked to do
certain things months from now and i
never think about
man
i'm actually gonna have to do it and
it's gonna suck i just never think about
that so i'm just like yeah months from
now it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
you really
you really should get a lot better at
that and and just think about
what if it was tomorrow
whether you do if it were tomorrow
good advice good advice luis is there
anything else that you would like to
add any requests of the audience
of course people can find you on twitter
at
luis van on they can find duolingo
duolingo.com or
anywhere they find their apps most
certainly they could find it
anything else that you would like to
add or mention draw attention to or
closing comments
i do have one thing although you know
you're welcome to cut it if you don't
think it's going to be all that
interesting but i would be remiss if i
didn't say this and it is it is about my
country guatemala
i would like to call attention
particularly here in the united states
about the level of corruption there and
you're like okay who cares guatemala is
corrupt
first of all it's extremely corrupt
and there are real consequences for the
united states and in particular one of
them is probably illegal immigration
there's you know guatemala is if it's i
think i believe the second country with
largest illegal immigration in the
united states there's a lot of there's
literally millions of illegal immigrants
from guatemala here in the united states
and you can be very concerned about that
and not only can you be very concerned
about the treatment of them in the
border which i think is horrendous but
you know once they're here like you can
be very concerned about that
and the sole reason why they're leaving
so much is because
the country is extremely corrupt and
just cannot
you know
handle itself basically
and the reason i like to call attention
to that is because i do believe the
united states and their foreign policy
can actually help with this
in many ways
and unfortunately
that is just not something that's
happening too much
but i do believe that as long as
guatemala continues to be this corrupt
they'll continue being a lot of illegal
immigration and i also think there's all
kinds of stuff i mean the thing is it's
so close to to the us
that it has become a hub for you know
basically international crime
and you know when they're close to the
us that means some of that crime spills
over to here
you know so far it hasn't happened but
we haven't seen like we haven't seen a
terrorist attack where the terrorists
came through guatemala but i wouldn't be
surprised if that happens where you know
it's just extremely corrupt place and
they just kind of funnel stuff from
there so
given that it's so close to
to this country i think this is of
importance and of course i have a
self-serving reason for saying this i
mean i would like my country to do
better but at this point the the level
of corruption there is is unbelievable
so that's the one thing that i um that i
would like to call attention to
that's why i asked i think this is a
perfectly fine place to talk about this
and let me ask you a follow-up
for those policy makers
people listening who may actually
be able to look at this more closely and
have an impact do you have any specific
recommendations or
requests
of them
i do
a number of them probably one of the
biggest ones is
there's a free trade agreement with
guatemala
the same one is nafta i mean there's a
free trade agreement with kind of you
know mexico and guatemala etc there are
classes there like anti-corruption
clauses
they are being overlooked
it is known that there is a lot of
corruption in a lot of these countries
and i think that the u.s can say you
know what
it's clear you're that corrupt
we're gonna we're gonna clamp down on
nafta unless you fix your problem and
this would get these countries to fix
their problems because they care about
something like nafta because they make a
lot of money off of it i mean money
moves things so that's that's one thing
another one is considering i mean there
are uh sanctions that they put to
individuals
the us has done these things where
certain individuals they just consider
them so corrupt that they're like sorry
you cannot enter this country anymore we
don't even want you to come visit you
know the shopping trip to miami or
whatever no no we don't want that
crazy story
some of the highest government officials
in guatemala including our attorney
general
is banned from entering the united
states because they're considered so
corrupt
applying more of that that actually has
real teeth and in particular applying
that to corrupt business people because
they all love their nice mansion in
miami or you know i bring up miami
because miami latin americans love miami
they love having mansions there they all
have their nice mansion in miami etc if
suddenly they cannot come to the u.s
that's bad and it looks bad for their
kids because their kids they love to
come to miami and their kids friends
lived so this is the type of stuff that
i think has teeth that that the us can
do
well thank you luis i did uh i did not
see that coming and i'm glad you brought
it up
i've thought about this problem a lot i
thought about this i mean i poured
millions of dollars to try to improve
i own
a good fraction of the oldest running
newspaper in guatemala and we we do a
lot of stuff against corruption so i
poured a lot of money onto this yeah but
unfortunately
i've kind of calculated that it's a lot
i think the corruption problem in
guatemala could be solved with some
money but i think it's like
billions of dollars unfortunately i have
not dropped that amount
but i put in millions of dollars to try
to fix this
all right what i might do is ask you
after
we stop this recording we'll get maybe a
few links for policy makers who may be
interested in in learning more about
this
and
the different
resources they might want to educate
themselves on
whether it's trade agreements or
otherwise so we'll get some links and
put those in the show notes
as well
and
luis thank you for making the time it's
nice to see you man it's been it's been
a little while thank you tim i mean and
for those who can't see the video i
appreciate the matrix-like background
that you have as well it's very
compelling
thank you tim i mean i'm studio i'm in a
great studio here near the dueling
offices
and uh hope to see you in person not too
long from now so maybe uh maybe we can
next time you're in new york city we can
figure out a way to to break some bread
or have a drink together i would love
that if you're in new york city i'm
there very often i would love that all
right wonderful well luis thank you so
much and
i always enjoy our conversations as i
mentioned before people can find you at
luis von on on twitter duolingo.com and
we'll link to
everything in the show notes at tim dot
blog podcast and to everyone listening
be just a little kinder than necessary
today and
thank you so much for tuning in
and until next time
take care
you